Luke here at the audro boys YouTube
channel and it's winter time here in the
Alaska mountains and I'm going to be
camping in deep snow I'm going to be
building my own shelter cooking good
food I'm going to be using snowshoes and
skis to explore these mountains and I'm
bringing you guys along for the
[Music]
ride
I think this is a good
spot this sled right here is called the
pul a couple weeks ago I was having
loads of trouble with it flipping on me
I think I solved it I went ahead and got
a second sled and I bolted the two sleds
together at the mounting brackets and
now if it flips over doesn't matter
additionally I put all my heavy stuff in
the pulk and all my big bulky light
stuff like my sleeping bag I put in my
backpack help keep the center of gravity
of my pulk lower those two things have
really helped I haven't had any trouble
today looks like the snow is 180 cm or 6
ft
deep
for
it's
oh I'm getting hungry I need a little
snack
break I think I'm going to indulge a
little bit I have myself a cherry fry
pie
oh oh These are
good all right I put my snow saww down
right over here and I can't find it
where did that thing go okay I'm going
to review my footage and see where I put
it
okay I think I know where it
is sure enough there it is that was so
Random
see that you can see light through the
snow when you can see light through the
snow that means you got less than 2 feet
to go so I'm getting
close
all
right
sh
all right I got the tarp up and just in
time the snow's really starting to come
down but uh I need to go ahead and seal
up the
edges it's almost 400 p.m. it's getting
dark can't leave anything on the ground
get
buried so you can see right here this is
going to be my bed tonight but it's not
exactly flat and I'd also like to push
that wall back a little bit so I'm not
right up against the
ice filled up my sled full of snow now I
got to take it out of
here
that's looking pretty good all right
we're going to use my probe and we're
going to measure the bed make sure it's
long enough all right so the bed looks
like it's about 8 ft long and that's the
minimum length I can handle I'm kind of
a tall guy and I want at least a few
inches of air in between me and any of
these ice walls if my sleeping bag rubs
up against any of the ice in the middle
of the night it'll get so cold kind of
not moving around as much it's starting
to get cold I think I need to put my
down jacket on I got to tell you it is
luxurious having a shelter you can stand
up
in oh if I had this tar pitched on the
ground like it normally would be I'd
have to be kneeling in the snow and ice
and it just sucks the heat out of you
not to mention it makes it really hard
to change your
clothes I'll tell you what I really love
these exped sleeping mats in the winter
time they are so warm and it comes with
this pump sack to help inflate it that's
a really common feature in all the major
camping Brands here in the
US there we there we go got plenty of
space I don't have to worry about
rolling off the edge or snuggling up to
the ice in the middle of the night this
will
work this is an emergency bivvy in case
you get caught in a snowstorm and you
need a quick shelter but also works good
to protect your sleeping mat or your
sleeping bag if you're sleeping in a
shelter rather than a
tent had a lot of trouble with my stove
last trip I went and cleaned it out
really good and seems to be working well
now
takes a little while for these sleeping
bags to fluff up in the cold give them
time wow that boiled so quickly all
right got some boiling bag
rice now we got these Curry packs let
them get
warm all
right
got some instant Japanese Curry here
just heat and
serve pipe and hot curry just sounds so
amazing right
now all this hot water and hot curry is
just steaming my shelter up I can tell a
real temperature difference between my
head and my feet my feet are kind of
cold my head's nice and warm all that
hot moisture is just rising to the top
of my shelter got to eat fast in the
winter time your food gets cold very
quickly you know that crazy thing is
this whole packet of Curry and a whole
packet of rice is less calories than
that one Fred
pie man that hit the spot I think I'm
going to make some
dessert check it out this is bread
pudding I just mixed all the ingredients
raw into the bag vacuum sealed it froze
it and now I just boil it for about 15
20 minutes and it'll cook in the bag and
I can eat
it there we go did the dishes my little
cooking table's a bit sketchy but I
really appreciate not having to cook on
the ground the reason why I'm using it
is I don't want to have to be down on
the ground it's hard on my back it's
hard on my knees and it gets is so cold
kneeling on the ground there's probably
a 10° difference between up here versus
down here temperatures dropping quick
I'm going to use some of these body
warmers these things are magic I love
them they last about 12 hours and they
have a sticker on the back slap one on
your chest one in your lower back these
things do work really
well I want some vanilla ice cream to go
with my bread pudding I just need one
key
ingredient nice fluffy stuff that's what
you
want all right we're going to make
vanilla ice cream we just need sweet and
condensed milk and some vanilla
extract there we go got a little cup of
homemade vanilla ice
cream all right oh yeah that's looking
good there we go a delicious bread
pudding well if you guys have never had
bread pudding it's basically french
toast you basically take eggs and cream
sugar vanilla raisins cinnamon mix it
all up pour it over chunks of bread and
then bake it or steam it yeah and it
tastes really good with vanilla ice
cream you can use the same technique
with a lot of different things you can
put cake batter in there brownie
batter oh that was good the snow ice
cream is really good it's a fun one to
try at home if you ever get a snow
day we got some powdered
Tang hot Tang on a winter camp out man
that's nostalgic that's what we used to
drink growing
up all right we're done not going to
waste this hot
water we're going to stick that into my
sleeping bag and get it all nice and
pre-warmed man I sure do love the fact I
can stand up in this shelter makes a
huge
difference all right got my puffy pants
I'm going to put those on and uh got
some down
slippers time to H on in it's nice
having an elevated
bed oh well I'll tell you what guys this
is cozy I'm nice and toasty warm and and
even though it's still cold in here this
is a lot warmer than some of the snow
shelters I've slept in I don't know if
you can hear it on the camera but it's
snowing so hard I can hear it hitting
the roof of the tent the snow isn't
sloughing off this shelter the way I'd
like it to and so it's kind of piling up
right here and
that's
and that's going to get heavy we get too
much snow it could cause the tent to
fall down on me in the middle of the
night and I don't want that so for the
next couple hours while I'm just sitting
here listening to my audio book I'm
going to keep an eye on
that lot of snow built up on the
de who that is getting
full it's 2:
a.m. woo it's really coming down now so
far I've had to clear off the tarp about
every 2 hours all right get
I
oh good morning snow s sof but it is
cold luckily it's warm in my sleeping
bag I'm just hanging out in here cuz I
don't want to get out oh my
back oh putting on Frozen boots always a
joy luckily my boots weren't too wet
last night so they didn't freeze up bad
and they're warming up pretty
quick oh there's my
gloves those are
frozen there's my gloves gloves were a
little bit wet last night so I put them
in the bottom of my bag they dried up
nicely stove warmed things up pretty
nice in here you see the frost is melted
on the inside of the tent my feet are
still cold but the top half of me is
warm oh my glasses are all fogged
up ah there you go nice and toasty warm
for breakfast we're having one of my
favorite meals biscuits and gravy got a
nice sausage gravy here stick that in
there let that warm up we're just going
to go ahead and sit them right just like
that let them get warmed
up all right I got to warm up my plate
so it doesn't chill my food there we
go oh I love biscuits and gravy biscuits
and gravy is one of the easiest meals
but it's so delicious heavy whipping
cream pork sausage lots of
pepper very traditional meal in the
southern
us
I'll tell you what this has not been a
bad shelter at all for the size of the
tarp I'm using I'm getting a lot of
space and when the stove's on it's
actually kind of warm you know from
about waist up I got room to store my
stuff I got an elevated bed the only
drawback is this tarp can't support a
ton of snow if it was snowing really
hard like you know 6 in every hour I'd
be clearing this thing off every 10 15
minutes when the snow gets a little bit
deeper though I can dig a proper snow
cave then you don't have to worry about
that
oh this is
pretty that is gorgeous I think I'm
going to do some
skiing oh I took it out we got a bunch
of ice fog here I think it's going to
burn off though we going to have a
gorgeous day
today
I'm skiing in my pulk tracks and it's
like the best groom Trail ever I feel so
light and
[Applause]
Nimble that Sun's starting to disappear
already not too far from the top
though
oh I made
it just in time too it's starting to get
dark oh
wow look at that
view Che it out on the bottom of my skis
I've got seal skin it's a synthetic fur
that allows me to scoot across the snow
and uphill now I'm going to take them
off roll it up you got to put them in
your pocket keep them warm otherwise the
stickiness will freeze
up so take this scoot that like
that now they're downhill
skis now I promise you won't laugh guys
I've only been downhill skiing once in
the last 20 years so I'm a little rusty
but but if you're going to fail what a
beautiful day to fail on and uh I'll do
it one-handed while I'm at
it so far so
good oh it's slowly coming back to
me
all
right oh just got a little bit of an
uphill part to go
through oh I'm getting the hang of it oh
I think I got the rust off but that's it
think it's time to switch back to my
skins
we're back in Cross Country mode took
about 2 hours to go up the mountain 20
minutes to go down but I feel like I got
some of the rust off I got to tell you
what this is a lot more enjoyable when
you're not pulling all that
Gear Well guys I hope you enjoyed that
video if you want to see more videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
make sure to click subscribe all right
guys I'll see you next video If you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for
watching